[Music]
hearing the latest news about China's
have been flow in global economic power
feels like riding a roller coaster when
things are going well for China the
headlines scream about how it's going to
overtake the US in the next five years
when things are going badly for China
you'll read about how it's done for it
will never catch up our research at the
global Capital allocation project takes
a step back to examine the larger
pattern in China's ups and downs one
thing we've been watching is how China
is trying to become a global Reserve
currency
a reserve currency is a currency that
other countries hold as a rainy day
account because it's going to hold up
its value when investors need it the
most in a crisis
for the last 100 years or so the US
dollar has been the world dominant
Reserve currency when a crisis hits you
and you need money if you have Bonds in
dollars you can sell them without losing
much value and because it's their own
country's currency the federal
government and American corporations
have the privilege of borrowing in
dollars at very low interest rates the
United States has their home court
advantage so to speak
China now wants to be a player in this
Reserve currency space
both to build its own Financial power
and to isolate itself from the financial
reach of the US
one way to do that is to
internationalize its captains and a
basic requirement of that is getting
foreign investors to participate in its
bond market that's a big deal China's
bond market is the third largest in the
world but until recently it was
essentially restricted to Chinese
residents foreigners couldn't really
invest there over the last 10 years that
has started to change and foreigners had
progressively entered this new bus
Market as China gradually opened up its
bond market to foreigners our research
found that it was strategic targeting
different types of investors at
different times at First China was only
looking for large official creditors
like foreign central banks or foreign
Sovereign wealth funds investors looking
for long-term stable returns that helped
get the world familiar with this new
market and started to build up China's
reputation as potentially a safe place
to invest
a few years ago China opened up to a
typical short-term investors like mutual
funds and hedge funds
surprisingly we found that the investors
holding Chinese debt are an unusual mix
some normally specialize in emerging
markets and others usually invest in
developed countries so investors see
China as somewhere in the middle
now China is still at the beginning of
this internationalization process and it
has a very tight route to walk our
research provides a framework to think
about China's strategy China needs to
build a reputation for being a place
where you can park your money where it's
liquid and safe meaning if you want to
take it out you can unfortunately part
of that means that if the rest of the
world gets scared about China and wants
to get their money out that sudden
withdrawal of capital will be expensive
for the country
now that it has allowed more and more
short-term investors this type of
capital flight is bound to happen in
fact through most of 2022 we saw some
foreign investors pull their money out
of China and historically it's been hard
for countries to resist the temptation
to prevent investors from fleeing that's
why it's really difficult to become a
reserved currency during China's next
political or financial crisis the
government might decide to shut down the
markets lock the gates on foreign
investors and get stuck with a terrible
reputation or they might find the
strength to go through their short-term
pain and build for the long run
ultimately why do we care about this
well this is a pattern that is going to
change the way money is invested around
the world if he continues for example
it's going to change how Americans and
Europeans invest abroad a big chunk of
what your Pension funds or mutual funds
hold could be in China and this could
push up interest rates in other
countries like the US
on the geopolitical side if China's
currencies becomes a viable alternative
to a dollar it will limit the United
States ability to freeze Bad actors out
of the world financial system
for example recent efforts to
economically punish Russia for its
invasion of Ukraine wouldn't be as much
of a threat to Russia if he had another
available option beside the dollar
of course the United States doesn't want
to be Eclipse as the epicenter of the
world financial system
so while China tries to build up that
faster base the US can try to keep its
good reputation by issuing a lot of safe
assets and making it clear it's a safe
and open market
it honors its promises and it pays debts
the U.S wants to signal to investors
that there is no need to go to China or
anyone else
[Music]
foreign